is single piece and I woke up today and  have not and don't do weekend events  because that's my family time and woke  up this morning and got here today was  to tell you one thing which is I  recommend it it's very seriously that  you go home and think about the fact  that you should probably allocate the  next three to four years of your life to  try to execute on the thing that you  want to do for the [ __ ] rest of your  life if you really want to do let the  thing that drives you that's when you  get into the zone of like cool I don't  need to live in the best place cool I'll  commute from a little further away cool  I'll team up with four live people then  sleep on a couch and I think that that  to me is the part that's most  interesting  the reason I'm willing to trade is  because I know how awesome it feels to  do what you love it's what I've been  able to do my whole life